we have aunt Sandra thought well God
speaking of peds what's up song yeah
yeah oh no it's Bill Maher that's cool
damn that is Bill Malloy's Bill Maher
dude he's getting he got jacked check
out the tits on Bill don't hate that
stupid cuz bill hates women - I don't
you know anything about building oh he
hates white women yeah he loves black
women unless they're really young dude
his last girlfriend was 19 years old so
if you are just past puberty you're good
but this lady has definitely a very Andy
Dick type of just dick sort of vibe
going how many rings do you think she
won is that Pat Riley dude put a couple
cigarettes in her jaw you know who that
is that's the lady that coach Tennessee
- 700 wins you right roll over other
lesbians in now you right cut that hair
for that Dyke haircut what's your name
summit Pat summit sum it up bro yeah sum
it up
oh I'll sum it up brother let's be
honest dawg ah very strong no ox
actually also very strong all the hard
work to make a good hard-working lady
her neck looks like my nutsack I'm just
commenting I'm what you put in front of
me what do you mean your vocal cords in
your nuts no I mean I got wrinkles oh
you gotta iron your nuts out there you
right I need that Botox on my nutsack oh
do you check out the new same me shout
out to her and as your rip drop what do
you guys think let's get asian let's go
fall man who's a bodybuilder - so I
can't I swear to God I do she's uh Miss
Universe I swear to God - what universe
dude name three universes I bet you came
what do you guys think of this let's get
Asian over here huh I feel like if she
was in the Vietnam War America would
have wanted
we sent her over to Iraq there would be
no Isis he definitely has that [ __ ]
GI Janis body you know who has that GI
James definitely
and she's got GI genetics two dudes he's
obviously on some performance making me
sweat bro touchy for me [ __ ] hey you
are meme row now I'll say this you seem
like a wonderful lady she's hard-working
hard work dude she's out there her arms
aren't that long and so I know it's she
didn't single yeah Jim what do you think
about she's divorced also oh uh you know
she kind of reminds me up and it's gonna
be mean I think I was know I'm talking
about
look she's a UFC fighter oh yeah Holly
Holm yes you're gonna say it remind you
of like Mickey Gaul or some [ __ ] no no
no like no not mickey Oh Mickey goes
much better looking in this way and
Mickey Rourke yeah yeah Mickey mustard
[Laughter]
did she send this to us brother this is
a human person that's alive in the world
right now yeah you're right with a lot
of testosterone in her [ __ ] veins and
it's easy to get guns these days I don't
need this heat I don't need to see what
cities Jin now I got a higher security
bring back the beautiful lady in the
wheelchair that was the first one dude
stand up for the picture to help that
was that car accident
ice box for us bring that big Krister
and Christie whatever her name was
Christie chris Christie Chris I'll shut
up to this lady a lot of hard work yeah
we already said that four times okay no
I will take it from here she seemed like
obviously she's good she's at the gym
cuz she's doing stuff it's daytime you
can see the light coming in the windows
in the bags I mean yeah she's getting
out there during the day and taking care
of herself
her tits are strong
Oh she'll breastfeed [ __ ] yogurt
break I'm saying breastfeed some cottage
cheese she's breastfeeding milk dude
it's got cereal in it bro with some
Christy relax
you [ __ ] kratom addict and you know
kradic kratom is a Schedule one narcotic
you know that I know and I love it him
your son keeps emailing me telling me
you're on it
daddy kratom and excuse me crying man
chop this lady's a lot of hard work to
get there she's Jack Brolin goes to the
gym every day that's true actually and
she seems like one of those ladies that
would do the pommel horse number that
she looks like spends a lot of time on
the cables the chest cables the pommel
horse
oh where they just did it yeah what's
that don't make a face contest those
little gymnasts are Jack central about
four seven but still oh dude they'll
piss brisk and they're so full of muscle
bro don't piss brisket
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]